David blaine's plan was to spend 44 days
in a see through plexiglass box dangling
from a crane near London bridge
subsisting on nothing but water.
He called the endeavor above the below,
which some observers considered a bit
much.
The British were not impressed.
They were not impressed when Blaine
pronounces venture at the most extreme
exercise in isolation and physical
deprivation ever attempted or when he
said,
I'm a great artist.
Nothing more,
nothing less.
There were not impressed by the
multimillion pound deal.
He struck with Sky Television and there
were not impressed that he had decided
to confine himself to glass prison and
voluntarily starve when so many people
were actually incarcerated in real
prisons and actually starving.
The mayor of London said it was
disrespectful to the IRA members who
died on hunger strikes in the 1980s
Blaine duly took his place in his box,
but the stunt totally backfired.
This is if it were the 18th century and
Blaine was in the stocks.
Crowns of cynical lenders gathered
underneath his box and laughed at him.
They pelted him with bananas,
French fries and eggs.
They made such a mess and his
girlfriend,
the unusually named German model,
Manon van Gherkin,
had to be cranked up on a crane to wash
the food to try this off the box with a
cloth.
We never had anything like this in New
York.
She said,
Blaine's helpers raise the box so it
would not be within egg throwing
distance.
A group of men position themselves on
tower bridge and tried to hit it with
golf balls.
A hamburger van pulled up below and
began ostentatiously frying onions and
other foods is enticing.
Aroma was designed to upset,
blame,
starving as he was a man tried to cut
off as water supply.
Some youth frightened him by shining,
lasered bends into his eyes.
A homeless person sat nearby behind a
sign saying,
please give generously.
I'm attempting 44 days on continuous
alcohol abuse.
Women took off their tops and flash
their breasts at Blaine.
Men pull down their pants and mooned
him.
People stayed up all night playing the
drums so this to disturb the tranquility
of anyone who might be trying to sleep
in an overhead box or radio station or
just listeners to stand in the cold
chanting,
Ding,
and then I'm noxious fashion.
Someone blasted the song living in a box
by the British pop funk group living in
a box,
a remote control helicopter buzz by
dangling a juicy looking cheeseburger on
a string.
There was unpleasant speculation about
Blaine's bathroom arrangements in
keeping with Britain's wellknown
lavatory obsessions.
Blaine's explanation of his plans for
his liquid waste that it would be
expelled by a to bleeding out of the box
had left a solid waste situation.
Deliberately vague adult diapers were
mentioned or radio host took to calling
Blaine nathey man.
Newspaper columnist speculated that the
illusionist had been eating on the sly
saying that they actually kind of fat
considering in the Sun.
Jane were referred to him.
Is that total twerp currently dangling
in a glass box above the Thames in the
Guardian,
Catherine Bennett said that the
satirical response to Blaine illustrated
the temperamental gulf between Britain
and America because Britain's know how
to tell the difference between a
huckster and a hero.
She urge Londoners to engage in a mass
public ridicule by taunting blend with
food,
even a blob of oily ice cream tastes
wizard when consumed in this suspended
company of the posture as close starving
Blaine,
she said,
true.
He did have a supporters including
American tourists,
regular visitors who believed they had
telepathic communication with him and
that he was sending them special signals
from the box.
People who felt sorry for him and the
parent normalist Uri Geller,
who announced he is the quality of
respite.
And when Blaine finally came down thin
and weak and with his major organs on
the verge of collapse or so,
he said the general feeling was that
above the below had been beyond the
absurd,
a huge pretentious failure.
But what was it that made ordinary
Britain's teas and resent him so much?
Because he was making such a big deal
about it because he had revealed himself
to be a puffed up self promoter rather
than the friendly kind of eccentric who
does what he does for himself rather
than for public acclaim,
news capable of going to the pub and
laughing at himself over a few pints
because he did not know when enough was
it.